[Musique]
bonsoir à tous tedx koulouba me donne
effectivement cette opportunité ce soir
de vous parler de la plante la plus
importante de l'histoire de l'humanité
il ya une dizaine d'années j'ai eu
l'occasion de visiter pas loin de ouaga
à pabré un jardin botanique un très beau
jardin botanique une collection de
plantes de l'afrique de l'ouest
notamment des plantes médicinales
certainement parmi les plus importantes
je faisais cette visite avec le père
césar que nombreux ici connaissent comme
un grand spécialiste des plantes
médicinales
nous passions devant un arbre il m'a
pris par l'épaule et il m'a dit mon
petit cet arbre il faut le regarder avec
beaucoup d'attention
cet art bat énormes potentialités on ne
fait que les découvrir je suis trop
vieux mois pour m'en occuper
tu doit intéresser à cela il a pas dit
plus je suis allé voir sur le net
le soir et j'ai compris que ma vie
allait changer parce que je découvrais
effectivement des potentialités très
importante d'une plante dont quelques
jours après j'entendais une conférence
du docteur hasan hatami logo et une
chercheurs de l'institut de recherche en
sciences de la santé qui me confirmait
effectivement cette importance cet arbre
on l'appelle parfois l'arbre du paradis
effectivement en dioula asia naïri en
moré hazen tig
on le dit aussi parfois miracle cuit
l'arbre miracle en allemand wunderbach
l'arbre merveilleux les sénégalais les
wolofs en particulier l'appel n'est
médailles et tenez vous bien des
médailles ça vient de never die
jamais mourir c'est pas beau quelques
intellectuels chercheurs n'ont pas
hésité à traduire ça directement en
français et c'est devenu le nez verdier
ni valdaï ni médaille ni verdier
cet arbre dont je vous parle est un
arbre extraordinaire et je vais essayer
de vous expliquer pourquoi
d'abord je n'ai pas eu l'angoissé de la
feuille blanche pour rédiger le début de
cette intervention
parce que c'est d'une magnifique feuille
verte plein de riches en nutriments dont
j'étais sur le point de pouvoir vous
parler
ensuite cet arbre fait une fleur si bon
voilà c'est une fleur tout à fait on y
vante passé dans une petite plantation
de moringa un soir de baisse de belles
chaleurs est certainement une des
expériences olfactives parmi les plus
extraordinaires
un parfum enivrant qui en dit long
je pense sur cette plante cette fleur
produit une gousse en l'occurrence un
espèce de grand haricots dans certaines
parties du monde dont l'appel le globe
stick free donc l'arbre baguettes de
tambour
il a beaucoup de noms donc dont on peut
extraire des graines ces graines qui
porte des grandes quantités d'huile dont
je vais vous parler mon ami d'aplats
moins que voici est un tradipraticien de
dano où j'ai vécu effectivement parmi
les dagara pendant quelques années
jusqu'à me sentir assez proche d'être
l'un d'eux et d'aplats - tradipraticiens
chef de terre qui je demandais pourquoi
on dagara ça s'appelle wanyou coin et
huanuco ans dans mon mauvais mort et ça
veut dire ou à baigneaux comme crocs et
boit de l'eau mange et boit de l'eau le
team c'est facile quand moi je vais en
brousse je regarde les génies dans le
marigot les gmi boivent de l'eau
indispensable à la vie et manche cette
feuille
cette feuille du wan yuko pourquoi ne
devrions pas de faire la même chose
voilà donc que cet homme qui était pas
un scientifique qui n'est pas un
intellectuel mais qui détenait sont ses
connaissances ancestrales savait
parfaitement et depuis longtemps qu
effectivement le moringa puisque c'est
de lui qu'il s'agit
cet arbre moringa représentaient une
source de vie une source de vitalité par
la richesse notamment qu'on lui
reconnaît en tant que nutriments le
moringa on peut le déguster en feuilles
on peut le côté et on en profite très
bien lorsqu'il est réduit en poudre
lorsque ses feuilles sont séchées est
réduite en poudre comme vous le voyez
sur la photo
cette poudre de moringa concentre un
cocktail absolument extraordinaire de
richesse de richesse nutritive avec
principalement trois familles une grande
famille de vitamines d'abord dont la
vitamine c qui dépasse tout ce qui est
connu au monde comme teneur par exemple
laurent jeu qui est très connu en
vitamine c elle battu très largement une
autre famille c'est les acides aminés
ces briques qui constituent les
protéines très importante et très
indispensable pour nos membranes
cellulaires pour nos cellules pour nos
organes il y a notamment en grande
teneur et donc de façon très importante
les neuf acides aminés qu'on appelle
essentiel parce que nous ne pouvons pas
les synthétiser nous devons les trouver
dans notre nourriture dans le moringa
ils y sont tous en bonne teneur et parmi
eux deux acides aminés qu'on appelle
acides aminés indispensables qui sont
particulièrement importantes pour les
nourrissons pour les petits enfants au
milieu de tout ça la troisième famille
c'est ce qu'on appelle les oligo
éléments et les minéraux dont je cite
quelques-uns dont vous connaissez
l'importance dans notre alimentation de
tous les jours le fer le calcium le
potassium etc qui sont vraiment là
encore présents en grandes quantités
il ya 92 nutriments qu'on trouve en
haute teneur dans le moringa dans le
moringa feuilles poudre mais aussi dans
le moringa huile puisque il s'appelle
moringa oleifera et oliveira ça veut
dire qu'ils portent de l'huile
ça veut dire qu'on le sait aussi depuis
très longtemps cette huile était
probablement l'huile des pharaons et des
pharaons on a longtemps cherché quel
l'huile l'extraordinaire est utilisé or
ce moringa existe en egypte et on pense
aujourd'hui que c'est celui qui a
utilisé cette huile est une huile
alimentaire d'abord avec une grande
partie des richesses que je vous
décrivais tout à l'heure mais aussi une
huile cosmétiques une huile de soin de
peau aux vertus exceptionnelles je
considère qu'elle fait partie des trois
meilleures huiles du monde avec le
beurre de karité d'ailleurs et donc ça
veut dire que dans notre faso nous en
avons deux qui pousse et qui qu'on peut
trouver très facilement
c'est très important c'est une huile qui
cicatrise c'est une huile qui est anti
inflammatoire antiseptique parfaitement
hydratante une huile sèche une huile
idéal est parfaite pour le massage donc
vraiment une très grande richesse
je vous ai dit toute la richesse
nutritive de cette plante
mais comment l'utiliser et là je ne vois
pas d'autre solution que de vous
raconter mon petit déjeuner il commence
par un jus de feuilles fraîches deux
feuilles cueillis dans mon dans ma cour
parce que il ya au moins une course sur
deux à ouaga dans les quartiers ou
ailleurs où on trouve le moringa même si
souvent ils ignorent vous prenez deux
feuilles vous laisse vous les laver avec
un peu d'eau de la banane du citron et
un miel
on mixe tout ça on a ce que vous voyez
derrière moi une bombe vitaminé
énergétique pour la journée je vous
assure qu'on prononce la reine cela vous
tenez très facilement jusque dans la
soirée
sans la moindre factice parce que ça
vous a apporté énormément de nutriments
j'ajoute à cela une tisane la tisane qui
est extraite du des feuilles fraîches ou
sèches
je fais un fusée un quart d'heure je
fais un bon litre un litre et demi qui
permet de boire tout au long de la
journée
l'important pour se réhydrater mais pour
apporter aussi bon nombre de nutriments
et parmi eux ceux que l'infusion n'a pas
extrait de la de la feuille
je prends ces feuilles je l'aimais soit
dans une omelette soit sur une salade
soit comme ici sur deux et sur le plat
je n'oublie pas d'y ajouter cinq ou six
graines de moringa piles et dont on sait
aujourd'hui scientifiquement le rôle
éminent qu'elles peuvent jouer dans la
régulation du diabète et de
l'hypertension deux véritables maladies
épidémiques dans le monde entier et
notamment ici en afrique et je n'oublie
donc pas ces graines qui une fois pile
est répartie sur ses oeufs sur le plat
sont parfaitement agréable comme
condiments et voyagent donc le cocktail
que je me suis fait le matin avec lequel
j'ai une perspective très intéressante
parce que le moringa m'aura apporté deux
de ses qualités essentielles qui sont
d'une part une augmentation considérable
de l'immunité l'immunité c'est ce qui
nous protège contre les agressions
quotidiennes de microbes de virus de
bactéries pour ça il faut se prémunir et
le moringa à cet immense avantage
notamment par sa richesse en
antioxydants
ce qui évite l'oxydation des cellules
des organes on va pas rentrer dans les
détails mais pour vous expliquer que si
j'ai un bon mur autour de moi je suis
protégé
et effectivement les gens qui consomment
régulièrement le moringa se retrouve
avec peu ou pratiquement pas de rhume
d'otites d'angine de douleurs
articulaires de fatigue dans la journée
etc
je vous assure pour en être un témoin
vivant que ça peut changer la vie et
l'autre aspect c'est que le moringa
contient 48 anti inflammatoires c'est à
dire ceux qui luttent au quotidien
contre une un phénomène qui est très
naturel mais qu'il faut jamais laisser
se développer
l'inflammation elle est utile pour ceux
encore une fois pour se prémunir de
beaucoup de choses mais la richesse
encore une fois du moringa
exceptionnelle en anti inflammatoire
donne là aussi une très bonne vitalité
est très utile effectivement pour sa
journée et pour avoir surtout des
protections au long cours c'est à dire
qu'il a aussi certainement un impact
sur un certain nombre de maladies de
jaillir de long tout le long cours comme
les cancers les maladies
neurogénératives etc
voilà comment vous pouvez à partir d'un
petit déjeuner quotidien
donc à partir d'une utilisation très
simple comment on peut avoir un grand
bénéfice de ce fameux arbre du paradis
vous retrouver là pourquoi on lui donne
tant de noms un petit peu qu'ils
paraissent parfois un peu pompeux mais
qu'on peut parfaitement expliqué
maintenant je vais vous montrer une
carte en espérant vous la voyez bien
elle n'est pas longue a expliqué en
rouge dans la partie basse les pays du
monde où malheureusement la malnutrition
et notamment la malnutrition des enfants
cbi encore de façon trop récurrentes en
vert sur la carte du dessus sur la
planisphère la carte de répartition de
cette plante éminemment tropicale et
seulement tropicale
ça veut dire qu'elle pousse pas en
europe et en amérique du nord par
exemple qu'est le moringa ça se passe de
commentaire
moi ça me met en colère chaque fois que
je vois cette carte elle est due à l'eau
wolf glee le canadien qui a au ghana il
ya une trentaine d'années mis en
évidence les premiers éléments qui
montrait la richesse du moringa quand on
voit cette superposition on se dit
premièrement que l'afrique n'est pas
pauvre mais elle a des richesses qui ne
sont pas encore valorisés et on se dit
qu'il faut faire quelque chose
ce quelque chose c'est se rendre compte
d'abord que le moringa est un enjeu de
sécurité alimentaire et sanitaire de
première importance
on a donc commencé il y a maintenant
presque dix ans à faire la culture du
moringa ce qui n'était pas une habitude
il fallait donc acclimater d'une
certaine manière vous n'avez pas précisé
que le manga n'est pas originaire de
l'afrique
tout comme le manguier ou le limier que
tout le monde connaît le moringa nous
est venue de l'inde
peut-être que quelques pèlerins de la
mecque l'avait déjà amené dans les
un moment ils revenaient du pèlerinage
mais c'est surtout par le biais du
commerce triangulaire de triste mémoire
que ces arbres sont arrivés et se sont
acclimatés à l'afrique
parfaitement c'est pour ça que on les
retrouve aujourd'hui avec une large peut
sembler possibilité d'être cultivé
j'ai commencé cette culture il ya une
dizaine d'années avec un groupement de
femmes à dano qui s'appelait tout pour
bien suivre pour connaître des femmes
veuves des femmes qui étaient en
difficulté qui cherchait des revenus des
femmes plus jeunes aussi qui cherchait
d'innovation et avec elle nous avons
développé comme vous le voyez sur la
photo des cultures de moringue qui
permettent de faire une activité
parfaitement moderne avec de la
technologie d'aujourd'hui
en l'occurrence du goutte-à-goutte en
bio j'insiste sur ce sujet on va pas
prendre des compléments alimentaires qui
serait polluée par des pesticides et on
a conduit effectivement une
expérimentation qui permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir développé des champs où on
trouve le moringa qui poussent vite
encore une caractéristique en quelques
six à huit semaines vous avez les
premières récoltes et après ça ne
s'arrête plus si vous iriez
régulièrement le moringa donc en tant
que culture représente une chance
absolument énorme que ce soit pour cet
aspect d'enjeux de sécurité alimentaire
parce que on peut le manger comme je
voulais dit au quotidien on peut en
faire des extraits de feuilles sous
forme de gélules de comprimés
l'introduire dans des aliments comme le
fait par exemple mon ami le chocolatier
andré bayala récemment qui a introduit
la poudre de moringa dans son chocolat
c'est un véritable délice que tout le
monde apprécie beaucoup mais on peut
effectivement aussi l'utiliser pour se
soigner parce que je préfère vous avoir
fait comprendre que c'est une plante qui
permet de prévenir les maladies et quoi
de mieux que d'essayer de rester en
bonne santé d'avoir de la vitalité
d'avoir de l'énergie de ne pas être
affaibli régulièrement même si c'est par
des petites maladies chroniques mais il
est aussi
eu une source de potentialités de soins
comme maladie de comme plante médicinale
qui est vraiment très importante et qui
a été reconnu d'ailleurs jusqu'au plus
haut niveau puisque j'ai la chance de
faire partie d'un groupe de travail qui
actuellement au niveau de l'organisation
des nations unies à new york
essaye de faire en sorte que le moringa
puisse devenir un peu un exemple
d'application et de concrétisation de ce
qu'ils appellent les objectifs du
développement durable ils ont défini il
ya un ou deux ans ces fameuses au dd qui
sont des grands classiques aujourd'hui
pour j'espère la plupart d'entre nous la
lutte contre le changement climatique la
lutte contre la désertification l'accès
à l'eau potable l'assainissement la
lutte contre la malnutrition des enfants
etc
l'onu a donc créé ses objectifs en
essayant de trouver des applications
concrètes et s'il ya vraiment une plante
qui montre aujourd'hui à quel point elle
peut permettre cela
c'est bien le moringa oleifera ce
moringa dont j'espère vivement
avec cet oiseau photographié il n'y a
pas tellement longtemps dans une
plantation que il permettra un envol de
l'afrique indique les puisque c'est le
thème de notre soirée indiquerez du
moringa je ne vous ai pas tout dit et
l'essentiel reste à venir
lebourrin gars donnée par un étudiant
burkinabè urbain son goût en 2012 2013
il a fait une étude dans un centre de
récupération d'enfants malnutris ici à
ouaga avec 10 g de la poudre de moringa
il a montré que les enfants sont
récupérées en 36 jours au lieu de 57
jours trois semaines de différence c'est
une étude qui a été publié elle est
aujourd'hui reconnue elle a été validée
on gagne trois semaines en donnant
seulement 10 grammes de pot de poudre de
moringa à des enfants en malnutrition
sévère
ils ont 7 % de diarrhée contre 80%
ciment pas le moringa alors
voilà mon témoignage voilà mon cri du
coeur si vous acceptez avec moi que les
arbres et les hommes blancs sont des
êtres comme tous les autres puisque mama
africa a su adopter le moringa je vous
demande à tous de nous aider à lui
permettre de nourrir ses enfants de bien
nourrir ses enfants
je vous remercie
[Musique]